le général de gaulle et le général
leclerc de figures de la france libre
durant la seconde guerre mondiale de
personnages historiques mise à l'honneur
dans une exposition à versailles nous
avons d'une part fait des recherches
dans les archives de la ville et nous
avons pu retrouver
des photos relatant la visite générale
des eaux plusieurs visites du général de
gaulle à versailles notamment quand il
était président de la république
et nous avons pu retrouver pour le
général leclerc des ces traces de son
passage à versailles tous les ans autour
du 11 novembre une exposition mémorielle
a lieu à versailles plus d'un millier de
petites pièces et de documents sont
présentés vous voyez autour de vous il
ya des panneaux donc qui nous ont été
fournies par d'une part la fondation de
la france libre et l'association de la
2e division blindée nous avons également
sollicité les versets y est alors
certain sur de grands collectionneurs
donc ils ont pu vous trouverez ici des
modèles réduits des
des mises en scène de petits personnages
retraçant certains épisodes de la
libération de la france et notamment la
libération de versailles un devoir de
mémoire important pour cette famille
jean-yves bien transmettre à ses petits
enfants cet épisode de l'histoire de
france c'est un mélange à la fois de
deux textes explicatifs d'une part et
puis d'autre part de représentation très
exact d
uniformes des habits donc cela nous met
en situation
il ya beaucoup de
objets qui nous montre comment c'était à
la guerre et puis mon grand père il nous
explique comment ça se passe et où
pascal il connaît il connaît tout ce qui
est en rapport avec les militaires le
thème de l'année prochaine est déjà
trouvé ce sera au tour du centenaire de
la pose de la première pierre du
monument aux morts de versailles édifié
le 11 novembre 1922